Rand really inspired a lot of people who
otherwise who otherwise might have
become conservatives like me if you go
back and look at surveys that were done
of libertarians in the 60s 70s and even
80s and said what single book or or
thought leader most inspired you to
become a libertarian and it was always
ran by a large large majority there
always a plurality and usually a
majority recent magazine came about
specifically as a influenced by Ayn Rand
lanny Friedlander the journalism student
who started reason as a mimeograph
publication was directly inspired by
Rand and then when I got involved and
Tibor McCann who was working on his PhD
in philosophy at UC Santa Barbara he and
I just really hit it off and and the
shared appreciation and inspiration by
Iran was a big part of that and was t
born I that came up with the idea to to
try to take it over take the magazine
over from lani who was about to go out
of business because he didn't have any
head for figures and had no business
plan and was running out of money so you
know we didn't we the business plan we
wrote didn't conceive of reason as an
explicitly Objectivist publication we
thought that would be too narrow in its
appeal we thought of it as a publication
inspired by objectivism and consistent
with objectivism ie a secular
enlightenment kind of culture and trying
to always give rational arguments for
things and to defend limited government
and free markets and capitalism but not
to be not to wear our chest like a
superman symbol but and to welcome
people who were libertarians in some
sense but but not necessarily Randy ins
because we wanted to reach a broad
audience we wanted reason to essentially
become the New Republic or national
review for libertarians you've took a
cross-section of people who think of
themselves with libertarians what would
the survey show about whether ran
was you know the still the predominant
influence I think libertarianism partly
thanks to reason and Cato and other
other organized institutions that we
didn't have 30 or 40 years ago has
reached out to a lot of people in a lot
of different ways so it's probable that
Rand is not as big of an influence on
what is now a much bigger community of
people but I thinks it's her ideas are
still very important I mean you find
Rams books on everything I didn't say
everybody's bookshelves but on lots and
lots of people's bookshelves and and you
get a discussion started at any event
where libertarians are and a lot of them
we'll have Randy and groups what's the
appeal of vine ran to people in general
but especially at college age I think at
college age people are looking for a
framework a mental framework for
understanding the world and ideas and
issues but also college students are
idealistic and you know I think people
who first encounter round in their 30s
or 40s often seem though this is
simplistic they aren't there no longer
as open to a radical completely black
and white view of the world now I mean I
as I've gotten older and more
experienced seeing how the world works I
understand that you don't make change
overnight that things are more
complicated but having that vision I
think when you're ready to shape view of
the world is can really be powerful I
think Rand influence is very much needed
today despite the fall of the Soviet
Union and the collapse of socialism per
se as an intellectual ideal for most
many intellectuals today the the big
problem is the growth of the welfare
state and a massive expansion of
government and and the blaming the
collapse of the capital markets on
capitalism or lazy fair I mean this is
of all this of all times we really need
a thoroughgoing fundamental defense of
the rightness of capitalism of
on unhampered markets at a time when
there's really i mean the Conservatives
and the republicans are offering no
defense really so it's all the more
relevant that we in effect rebuild the
case for limited government capitalism
and a truly free society so i think we
all have our work cut out for us and in
rands vision and and the the inspiration
that this is the morally right way for
free people to live and people to be
responsible for their own decisions this
really needs to be said in these times
the idea that the government should bail
everyone out who acted short-sighted lee
and foolishly over the last five years
or ten years whether it was taking out a
you know too many home equity lines or
buying houses they couldn't afford or
financial institutions really doing
stupid things let's have now is the time
for for responsibility which is a core
importance for a free society
you